اعلنت سلطات تركيه في حاله التاهب الجوي
في العاصمه الاوكرانيه ومناطقه اخرى في
البلاد
وارجعت سلطات كيف ذلك الى وجود التهديد
باطلاق الصواريخ بالتزامن مع تحليق
الطيران الروسي في بحر قزوين ودعت مواطنها
الى الاختباء في المنهج واتباع ارشادات
سلطات المحليه للحمايه من اي هجوم صاروخي
ميدانيا نقلت وكاله رويترز عن القياده
الجنوبيه للقوات الاوكرانيه
استهدفا من جهتها بثت القوات الروسيه صورا
قالت انها لقصف براجمات الصواريخ على
مواقع القوات الاوكرانيه في باخمود جنوب
شرقيه اوكرانيا امس الاربعاء
نعود الى التطورات الميدانيه في اوكرانيا
وينضم اليها من كيف مراسل الجزيره المعتز
بالله حسن يا مرحبا المعتز بالله سياق
حاله التاهب الجوي التي اعلنت في كيف
ومناطق اوكرانيا اخرى
مع كل انذار جوي هذا يعني ان هناك هجمه
صاروخيه على اوكرانيا هذه الهجمه اين هي
لا يمكن تاكدها قبل تصدي المضادات الارضيه
همم لصواريخ العابره او سقوط قذائف في
مكان ما وبالتالي حاله الانذار الجويه
باتت امرا متكررا خلال الفتره الماضيه
ولكن مع كل انذار جويه هناك همم
هجمه صاروخيه يقول الاوكرانيون انها
تستهدف مناطق حيويه في اوكرانيه اليوم
هناك اخبار عن ان الهجمه الصاروخيه التي
همم تم همم اطلاقها اليوم فقط بعضها في
مناطق دينيرو شرق اوكرانيا ومع ذلك هناك
همم حاله من ال- همم التاكيد الاوكراني
على ان روسيا هي ماضيه في عدوانها ولا
تريد تحقيقه اي تقدم مع هذه الهجمه دعنا
نذكر انه في يوم امس الاول كان هناك هجمه
صاروخيه كبيره استهدفت قطاع الطاقه اكثر
من 100 صاروخ ايضا كان هناك قضيه الصاروخ
الذي وقع داخل الحدود البولنديه والذي
تسبب بتراشق بين كيف و موشكو عن تبعيه هذا
الصاروخ وايضا التصريحات من الاوروبيين
الرئيس الانسكي الى الان هو يؤكد ويصر على
ان هذا الصاروخ هو ليس اوكرانيا ويقول ان
لدى اوكرانيا معلومات كافيه في هذا المجال
وهو مستعد لمشارتها ويقول ان قياده الجيش
اخبرته بان هذا الصاروخ هو صاروخ روسي
وبالتالي هو همم يصدق قاده جيشه ويقول ان
اوكرانيا يجب ان تشارك في تحقيق مشترك في
هذا الموضوع وهو مستعد لتقديم المعلومات
التي بين يديه للراي العام وفي خلال
تحقيق المشترك لهذا الصاروخ هناك